there's probably people think more
preparation than there really was which
for someone like me even scarier right
um someone asked me earlier was it
pre-recorded no it was all live there
was all me all everybody like if you
went down you went down live in huge
audience by the way um it was so scary
we had probably for the first song like
maybe three weeks rehearsal and not like
once a week for her so like you know Amy
I was like I'm not a trained singer I
need more rehearsal I took every
opportunity I could to rehearse we got
this great choreography amazing
choreographer I got to do all these
dances and stuff that then on stage in
costume I couldn't do anything yeah so I
was like I'm just lucky if I can move
and sing the song I learned all these
dances Tori Spelling spilling secrets
about the masked singer
well that mask was so heavy I literally
could have fallen on my face but I was
just like concerned like what if I go up
there and like I go to sing and nothing
comes out it's like that being naked at
school thing like what if nothing comes
out and make to stop it and like I have
I was like okay stop it stop it but yeah
I just I still don't know this right now
performing in front of people is my
biggest fear in life I mean there's
really no getting ready like if you
choose to yes like I chose to like you
know get myself prepped in unicorn mode
but you arrived and literally a car
picks you up they don't know who you are
they're not allowed to talk to you you
put a mask on when you get there before
you enter the studio a lot you have to
put the black hoodie on because it was
super hot while we're filming and then
they put and then you get dressed in
that trailer and it dressed no you wear
that yeah to the set and then like a
little curtain behind the set you get
dressed right before because I couldn't
see so I couldn't get dressed in like
and I couldn't breathe like I got
dressed right before and like got into
my fight zone
[Applause]
how do you rehearse a group routine and
not know who's in the group we rehearsed
it not with each other we only had one
rehearsal because by that time like it
starts to get less and less rehearsal as
you go on
you're then shooting like two shows a
week like it was like crazy I think my
last performance I had two days to learn
my song my dance my movement where I was
going plus the group song so we
practiced it without and then we had to
practice it the date of in costume if I
was like but that was my first time like
kind of on stage with waianae like it
was like oh my gosh
and you go up to them and you're like
hey lion we're going to talk to each
other like all I know is I saw a rabbit
backstage like doing his moves begin
talk to me like I still know who rabbit
is I'm like fascinated to see if I'm
guessing just like America's guessing